y ahora haré una prueba de la ley de los
senos entonces primero voy a dibujar un
triángulo que no tiene por qué ser
equilátero o rectángulo
es un triángulo el que sea así que
tenemos aquí un lado otro lado y de
hecho lo voy a hacer ver un poco raro
para que veas que aplica a cualquier
tipo de triángulo y digamos que sabemos
la siguiente información conocemos este
ángulo este ángulo de aquí aunque bueno
de hecho no voy a decir que sabemos lo
que no sabemos de esto pero la ley de
los senos es simplemente una relación
entre diferentes ángulos y diferentes
lados entonces digamos que este ángulo
es alfa este lado su longitud es anne y
digamos que este ángulo es beta y la
longitud de aquí es b
ajá entonces este es b y acá el ángulo
beta ahora la longitud de aquí es b y
bueno veamos si podemos encontrar una
relación que conecta a b
alfa y beta y bueno que podemos hacer
espero que la relación que encontremos
sea la ley de los senos porque en otro
caso yo tendría que poner otro título a
este vídeo pero bueno dibujar una línea
aquí desde este vértice am así que bueno
yo dibujo una línea que va derechito
hacia abajo y de hecho será una línea
perpendicular a este lado de abajo el
lado el lado desconocido a un a uno le
pongo nombre pero si debo ponerle el
nombre le voy a poner se porque ya
tenemos el lado a el adobe así que éste
queda el a 12 y aquí tenemos un ángulo
recto ahora yo no conozco la longitud de
eso no sé nada simplemente de este
vértice yo dejé caer una línea que es
perpendicular al otro lado entonces
bueno qué podemos hacer con esta línea
si yo digo que esta línea tiene longitud
x así que esta línea tiene longitud x y
bueno podemos encontrar una relación
entre a la longitud de esta línea xy
beta lo que voy a hacer es bueno voy a
cambiar el primero de color a ver cuál
él dijo ahora bueno si nos enfocamos en
este ángulo
si nos enfocamos en este ángulo x es
opuesto a beta y aer la hipotenusa y si
nos enfocamos en este triángulo
rectángulo que identidad tiene opuesto
sobre hipotenusa siempre hay que
queramos trigonometría debemos
recordarnos del soca toa baja entonces
opuesto hipotenusa es el seno si ves así
que bueno muy bien vamos por buen camino
de hecho si estoy entonces probando la
ley de los senos y veamos si el seno de
beta es igual a cateto puesto sobre
hipotenusa x es el opuesto entonces es
igual a x sobre la hipotenusa la cual es
am y si quisiéramos resolver para x lo
cual haré porque bueno será será
conveniente después entonces
multiplicamos ambos lados de la ecuación
por an y obtenemos de esta manera a seno
de beta
a seno de beta es igual a x cierto o que
bueno muy bien hasta aquí entonces bueno
veamos si podemos encontrar una relación
entre alfa ibm y x similarmente si
observamos este triángulo rectángulo
porque claro también es un triángulo
rectángulo x aquí aquí relacionado con
alfa es también el lado opuesto y ves la
hipotenusa entonces bueno también
podemos escribir que es seno de alfa
entonces bueno lo escribo entonces seno
de alfa es igual acá te propuesto sobre
hipotenusa opuestos sobre hipotenusa
entonces cateto opuesto es x y la
hipotenusa es b entonces bueno
resolvemos para x
similarmente multiplicamos ambos lados
por b y obtenemos b b por seno de alfa
es igual a equis y que tenemos aquí
tenemos dos distintas maneras
con las que resolvimos para la línea x
la línea que deje caer
perpendicularmente la línea x entonces
tenemos que hacer no de alfa es igual a
xy que ve seno de alfa es también igual
a equis y bueno si ambos son igual a
equis entonces ambos son son iguales de
acuerdo pues sí así que voy a escribir
eso lo escribo en diferente color
entonces sabemos que hace no de beta es
igual
a x lo cual también es igual a veces
seno de alfa de seno de alfa y si
dividimos ambos lados de la ecuación por
an que obtenemos bueno pues ahora es 1
así que obtenemos que seno de beta es
igual a b seno de alfa sobre a y bueno
ya con esto si dividimos ambos lados por
ver vamos a hacerlo vamos a dividir
ambos lados por ver entonces obtenemos
seno de beta sobre b
es igual
a que es igual al seno de alfa sobre a
cierto esto es igual al seno de alfa
sobre an y bueno aquí ya tenemos
finalmente tenemos lo que queríamos esta
es la ley de los senos es la razón la
razón entre el seno de beta y su lado
opuesto el lado opuesto que le
corresponde al ángulo beta eso es b y
bueno eso es igual al seno de alfa y su
lado opuesto sobre su lado opuesto
entonces de hecho lo puedes ver en
muchos libros y suponemos que esto es
teta y aquí este es el lado c
entonces obtendríamos seno de teta sobre
ser seno de teta sobre c y bueno de
hecho la prueba para poder agregar aquí
esto es idéntico escogimos sabe
arbitrariamente podemos hacer lo mismo
con con teta y con cesc cierto pero en
lugar de dejar caer aquí una línea
perpendicular la altitud desde theta
bueno dejamos caer la desde otro ángulo
es bastante sencillo porque lo puedes
intentar ahora que aquí también a otra
cosa que me parece muy interesante es
que bueno estas son razones entonces tú
puedes sacar sus inversa cierto podemos
escribir b sobre seno de beta
sobre seno de alfa lo cual también es
muy útil porque tú conoces un lado y el
ángulo que le corresponde su ángulo
opuesto es decir aquí está el dato
curioso en lo importante es que si tú
conoces tres de estos lados
tú puedes saber bueno tres de estos
datos entonces tú puedes conocer el
cuarto dato si conocemos a quienes hay
quienes ve y quien es seno de alfa
entonces podemos conocer quién es seno
de beta a partir de esos tres y eso es
lo mágico de la ley de los senos bueno
nos vemos